the psychiatric times wrote this article
is video game addiction a disorder
in ohio a 17 year old boy shot both of
his parents killed it killing his mother
because what a great story you put here
tyler thank you for the soft story these
feel good because they took away his
halo because they took away his halo 3
video game his defense was that he was
pushed to the brink uh by his addiction
to video games often playing for 18
hours straight and south korea a couple
was arrested for being so obsessed with
video games that their infant daughter
died of malnutrition okay now this is
these guys have issues here 18 hours a
day in response to
statistics like this the world health
organization in 2010 officially included
internet gaming disorder icd in the
international classification of diseases
noting that this is disorder resulted in
marked distress or significant
impairment in personal family social
educational occupational functioning who
further noted that associate health
concerns including insufficient physical
activity poor diet problems and eyesight
with eyesight and hearing
sleep deprivation aggressive behavior
and depression as well as poor cycle a
psychological functioning in 2020
consumers in the us spent
57 billion dollars on video games
beating 2019 by 27
projections that by 2023 next year that
57 billion is going to be 217
billion dollars how much of this is on
the kid how much of this is on the
society how much of this is on their
parents
i think there's a bigger debate about
addiction we can come to in a second but
if you think about these video games
this is going to be too negative an
analogy but let me say it and then i'll
explain why it's a bit too negative if
you think about them as a virus right
that come along that would be compelling
in any situation
they've arrived at a moment when kids
immune systems are already down right so
they're more likely to be infected by
the virus and for it to take them over
so i'll give you two examples
children now sleep 85 minutes less than
they did a century ago now you all know
we all know if we've had a night where
we haven't slept you're much more likely
to just spend next day mindlessly scroll
through tiktok than you are to read a
book right so partly our kids are
severely sleep deprived and that is
making them more vulnerable to this
stuff also the diet our children eat um
the food we feed our kids makes them
much more vulnerable to this stuff as
well and i stress again it's some of it
some of the video gaming is good but you
think about how we eat there's three big
ways in which the way we our kids eat
and the way we eat in fact is damaging
our ability to focus and make you as
more vulnerable to the kind of things
you're describing the first is so
imagine you have the standard american
british breakfast the kind of thing i
grew up having i'm sure you guys did
kind of sugar or in germany sugary
cereal or white bread with butter or
whatever right what that does is that
releases a huge amount of energy really
quickly into your brain right and it
feels great you're like i've [ __ ]
woken up you know you've got a rush of
glucose but what happens is you'll get
to your desk or your kid will get to
their school desk an hour or two later
and you get a huge energy crash
because you know the way dale pinnock
one of the leading nutritionists in
britain put it to me
is it's like you're putting rocket fuel
into a mini with you know those little
british cars that's right it'll go
really fast for five minutes then it'll
just stop right so the way we eat causes
energy spikes and energy crashes which
leaves you with brain fog when your
energy crashes you get brain fog you
just can't think clearly until you have
another sugary carby snack right
so
one of the things that we're doing is we
if you
by contrast if you eat a f if you eat
food that releases energy steadily
throughout the day which is what you
know almost all our ancestors ate you're
able to pay attention more evenly and
you're less likely to just get into
these slumps where just anything that
wants to [ __ ] with your attention will
seem appealing second way
our diet is damaging our ability to
focus
is the um
your brain in order to develop properly
needs certain nutrients and the diet we
currently is lacking a lot of those
nutrients like omega-3s and supplements
don't cut it because your body doesn't
absorb supplements in the same way third
way is to me the most shocking and i
think to you as the dad most
most relevant although they all are
which is there was a it's not just that
our diets lack things we need
they contain chemicals that act on us
like drugs so there was a study in
britain in a city called southampton in
2007. they got nearly 300 kids and they
split them into two groups the first
group was just given water and the
second group was given water lace with a
load of the food dyes that occur in the
kind of food you get in the supermarket
in m ms that kind of thing
and then they monitored them the kids
that drank the food dies were
significantly more likely to become
manic to run around which would have
made them more vulnerable to the kind of
things you're talking about so you can
see how and these are just two of the
many factors that i talk about in the
book that are affecting our kids
attention so you can see how that's like
lowering your immune system so that when
something that wants to [ __ ] with your
attention comes along it's easier for it
to infect the child which is not to say
there aren't healthy uses of video games
that totally are i'm not opposed to
video games just like i'm not opposed to
technology or the internet more
generally but we've got to look at these
things but there's a bigger debate about
addiction that i can talk about where i
think this video game addiction stuff
um how would i put it
i think it can be interpreted this is
not what you're doing but i think it can
be interpreted simplistically and this
is because i went on a long journey
about learning about addiction for a
previous book i wrote called chasing the
screen where
there's a lot of addiction in my family
one of my
earliest memories
um it was it was mostly prescription
drugs um
so one of my earliest memories is trying
to wake up one of my relatives and not
being able to and um
funny enough it's similar places iran
and germany were two to the countries my
family lived in as well so similar to
you um
and
when i started doing research on
dictionary almost exactly 10 years ago
if you had asked me about let's say
heroin addiction because that was also
close to me
if you ask me what causes heroin
addiction
i would have looked at you like you're
an idiot and i would have said well
patrick the clue's in the name
obviously heroin causes her addiction
we've been told this story for a hundred
years that's become totally part of our
common sense i thought it was
i mean i thought i'd seen it unfold in
front of me right
so we think if we kidnapped the next 20
people to walk past your offices here in
florida
and we injected them every day with
heroin three times a day for a month say
like a villain in a sore movie
at the end of that month they'd all be
heroin addicts for a simple reason
there's chemical hooks in heroin that
their bodies would start to get used to
and then their bodies would start to
desperately physically crave them and so
at the end of it they would have this
tremendous physical hunger for the
chemical hooks right that's why we call
it being hooked right you want the
chemical hook
it turns out that story's not wrong
chemical hooks are real but it's a
really small part of what's happening
with addiction
and when you look at the bigger picture
and i only really began to understand
this when i went to vancouver and
interviewed a man named professor bruce
alexander who did an experiment that has
transformed how we think about addiction
he explained to me the story we got in
our heads addiction is caused primarily
or tightly by the chemical hooks comes
from a series of experiments that were
done earlier in the 20th century they're
really simple experiments your viewers
can try them at home if they're feeling
a little bit sadistic
you take a rat you put it in a cage and
you give it two water bottles one is
just water and the other is water laced
with either heroin or cocaine
if you do that the rat will almost
always prefer the drugged water and
almost always kill itself within a
couple of weeks it'll overdose so there
you go that's our story the rat tries
the drug wants more and more of it dies
but in the 70s professor alexander came
along and said well hang on a minute
you're putting the rat alone
in an empty cage
it's got nothing that makes life
meaningful for rats all it's got is the
drugs what would happen if we did this
differently
so he built a cage that he called rat
park which is basically heaven for rats
right they've got loads of friends
they've got loads of cheese they've got
loads of coloured balls they can have
loads of sex anything a rat likes in
life is there in wrap park and they've
got the drug water the normal water and
the drug water and of course they try
both they don't know what's in them this
is the fascinating thing
in rat park they don't like the drug
water very much
none of them use it compulsively
none of them overdose so you go from
almost 100 compulsive use and overdose
when they don't have the things that
make life worth living to no compulsive
use of overdose when they have what you
were talking about before meaning
purpose the things that make life worth
living for them and what i learned from
this there's loads of human examples we
can talk about but what i learned from
this is that the opposite of addiction
is not sobriety valuable though that is
to many people the opposite of addiction
is connection and the reason i say this
in response to this video game addiction
uh stuff you read out patrick
is
i think it's too simplistic to say oh
the video game this boy that you
described i don't know how old he was
17. yeah this 17 year old boy it's way
too simplistic to say the video game did
that tim right the video game did that
to him in a context where also i'm sure
absolutely the story but i'm sure all
sorts of things were [ __ ] him up and
every addictive behavior
whether it's video games cocaine porn
whatever it might be
is an attempt to not be present in your
life because your life is too painful a
place to be right you want to not be
present so you obsessively use the porn
you obsessively play video games
whatever it might be that helps us to
understand by the way why what we do
here in the us
is such a [ __ ] disaster with the war
on drugs because what we do
is we get addicted people and we say oh
we need to inflict more pain on them in
order to give them an incentive to stop
but when you know that pain is the
[ __ ] fuel pain is the driver you can
see sometimes we say it doesn't work
truth is much worse it makes the
addiction worse right
does that all what do you what do you
make of that about your thoughts the
first thing that popped in my mind you
said is is
all right they're in a cage
so the thing that comes to my mind is
we've seen the stats on what's happened
since kovit everyone's been locked in
their cage
right other than maybe here in florida
and other certain other states
so
if you have the choice of just sipping
on water or sipping on water with heroin
if you're the rat and you're in your
cage you're gonna take the heroin
using a human example if you're sitting
at home alone doing nothing
you know you have to work apparently
maybe you're not maybe you're collecting
unemployment you're getting stimulus
checks maybe you've got to hop on a zoom
do work but you're locked in your
proverbial cage okay there's some liquor
in the cabinet there's some pot over
there on the desk maybe there's some
harder uh
you know pills opiates they're sitting
there you're in your cage
so
i'm sensing this cajun alley is what
analogy this is what leads to people
saying well based on the two options i
have of sipping on water or doing some
drugs i'm in this cage anyway let's
party is that part of what this rat cage
analogy is
yeah i've got a friend um so as you know
we
interesting i want to read this comment
before you go which validates your point
uh crypto trends uh 101 i used to be
addicted to meth i know sad but it's
true the environment
and things worth living for are what
made me better
yeah i think this really fits with what
you're saying adam which is that so a
lot of people watching will know uh in
the last year we had the highest
overdose deaths ever and that's
staggering because just before the
pandemic
people thought well it can't go higher
than it is now
um and
my friend the writer andrew sullivan
said to me it's like we did an
experiment to see if you were right
right i've been saying for 10 years the
opposite of addiction is connection
if you increase disconnection you'll
increase addiction
and here we are right we increase
disconnection in what may be justified
cause but it has caused a horrific
increase in not just addiction and this
fits with a wider way of thinking right
which is that everyone listening and
everyone watching knows that you have
natural physical needs right obviously
you need food you need water you need
shelter you need clean air if i took
those things away from you you'd be in
real trouble real fast but there's
equally strong evidence that all human
beings have natural psychological needs
you need to feel you belong human
connection you need to feel your life
has meaning and purpose you need to feel
that people see you and value you you
need to feel you've got a future that
makes sense
and
if you if you deprive people of their
psychological needs
that will manifest in all sorts of
problems you'll have increased suicide
which we have you'll have increased um
homicide which we have right you'll have
increased um
addiction which we have an overdose
deaths and you can see this this is why
some of the best people who've studied
this professors and case and angus
dayton called the opioid crisis deaths
of despair when a factory shuts down in
a town the over the next five years the
death rate among people who work there
more than doubles right now that's not
difficult to understand anyone who hears
that knows immediately why right
so it's not of course the drug plays a
role just like the video game may in
this case i don't know anything about
this particular case but the video game
may play a role but but the drug in the
video game
enter in a context and most people who
use even quite hard drugs and this
really surprised me because it wasn't
the experience of my family but if you
look at the evidence from people like
professor carl hart at columbia
university and others
most people who use even quite hard
drugs like even meth and heroin do not
become addicted and are not harmed by it
now of course there's a minority you are
harmed you need our love and support but
why can some people do it and not others
there's some biological contribution
some people have a little bit more of a
genetic
vulnerability but most of it is about
these bigger psychological and social
factors if your life's going well
you know and you're happy and you want
to be present in your life you can
probably snort a line of coke you'll be
okay if you're if the factory is shut
down and you're stuck in a place like
monadnock new hampshire where i went
where people are in deep despair through
no fault of their own you know well it's
going to be a lot more dangerous for you
because you're going to want to not be
present in your life so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]